my name is me
graduate admissions and it's my
privilege today to introduce our
afternoon faculty speaker professor Don
Melnick professor melmac is Thomas Hunt
Morgan professor of conservation biology
in the department of ecology evolution
and environmental biology at columbia
university he's also the director of the
Center for environment economy and
society a group that integrates natural
science economics and business in an
effort to conserve biological diversity
at global national and local scales a
magna laud graduate in anthropology
and history from New York University he
was also a member of Phi Beta Kappa
there he received his doctorate in
physical anthropology focusing on
molecular genetics from Yale University
and then joined the Columbia faculty
university in 2000 professor Melnick
developed the blueprint for the creation
of the department of ecology evolution
and environmental biology or what we
call iii-b he also spearheaded the
process leading to its acceptance by the
Faculty of Arts and Sciences in 2001
thus creating the first truly new
Columbia arts and science department in
over half a century most recently
professor Melnick assumed the role of
co-chair of the United Nations
Millennium Task Force on environmental
sustainability professor Melnick is
currently advising several heads of
state around the world on ways to
achieve environmentally sustainable
economic growth in this effort he's
helping each country to integrate the
best science with the political and
economic imperatives that currently
exist and will exist in the future for
30 years he's used molecular genetics to
explain aspects of the ecology behavior
evolution and conservation of
vertebrates now a side story about
professor Melnick that shows us true
devotion to the lies of undergraduates
for six years he was one of our faculty
and residents actually living in a
residence hall and creating programs for
students in that residence hall tying
interesting academic issues to residents
life issues professor Melnick has agreed
after we're finished with his
presentation to stay and answer
questions from students Thank You
professor switch microphones I think
this microphones on can you hear me ah
great well it's a big turnout thanks for
coming um actually I tell you a very
quick funny story about when we were the
faculty family in residence in Shapiro
Hall which is just a block to the west I
think they're about 420 undergraduate
saying and we used to try to have
programs where we would invite
well-known people in from New York to
the program and invite then invites
students and one evening we had Wynton
Marsalis come first for a dinner with
about 20 students which was really fun
for the students then we went across the
hall to a bigger area for dessert for
there any other students that want to
attend and the one thing he insisted was
that he was not going to bring his any
instruments and play instruments he was
not going to play music and over the
course of the evening all he did was
described this and that and then use his
fingers like this and simulate a trumpet
just by playing a did that all evening
long so he didn't come with a instead it
was a great evening and to me it was
really indicative of columbia college
students because everything he said they
challenged him on everything at the end
of it he sort of left going god I'm
exhausted so anyway I'm going to give a
talk today about what it's been like to
be a university scientist for the last
30 years
and I know there are a lot of students
who are thinking about Columbia and I
know that all of you have I
self-identified as interested in science
so I'm going to mix sort of science with
experiences that have happened along the
way okay so we'll start from the
beginning the early years I know that
images are not so great because of the
light coming in the ambient light but in
any case this is actually an aerial view
of this neighborhood in the 1950s
actually and about Morningside Heights
neighborhood and this is actually was
called Women's Hospital is where I was
born I was actually born only about five
or six blocks from here the hospital was
torn down shortly after I don't think
the two things are related my being born
in that but what did go and it doesn't
exist anymore it's on 110th Street
between amsterdam and columbus and my
parents moved out you know as part of
the sort of post-world war two post
korean war moved out to the suburbs
because there was a money available to
move out to the suburbs and we went out
to the suburbs and so I grew up in a
really small town really small like
5,000 people and you can see you know
down by the railroad tracks and I just
look like little small-town kid but I
always was extremely interested in
nature so I had a butterfly collection
that's actual picture of my butterfly
collection I still have that butterfly
collection unfortunately some of those
species are no longer in the place where
I grew up they've been locally
extirpated in addition I'd love to go to
the shore this is actually on the North
Shore you can tell because it's all
pebbles North Shore of Long Island soul
pebbles the Long Island Sound has
pebbles and I have a shell collection
still have my shell collection they've
continued to collect over all these
years notice those snazzy binoculars i
have around there those are pretty cool
huh so I was kind of a budding
naturalist and I really really love
nature i won't go into all of the
stories about how much time I but I one
of the things I really love to do as a
kid was declined to the tallest tree we
live near a big wooded area that once
farm and had grown back as far as
climbed to the tallest tree because I
really wanted to see what it was like to
be a bird what it would be like just
what a bird would see when they were
looking down needless to say this that
not my mother didn't appreciate this
habit of climbing to the tallest tree so
when I was about eight or nine years old
I came out one day in the yard and I saw
this and you have to do this was sort of
the late 50s early 1960s when it was the
Cold War we were all afraid of being
bombed of an atomic bomb you know we'd
have these crazy drills we'd go
underneath the desks and put our hands
over our head as if that was going to
protect us against an atomic bomb but we
would do that anyway and so there were a
lot of movies and these movies they
he'll have this theme the theme was
there's atomic testing out in a desert
somewhere and it creates a mutant form
of an insect and some large ants or
large flies or something like that
emerges and begins to attack the human
population so I came out and I saw this
thing and blew me it looked like a fly
after I was only about eight years old
and it was pretty big it was like three
three-and-a-half inches I thought I went
running in the house and I said we have
11 of these irradiated flies you know
it's incredible later on I learned that
it was a cicada and that they come out
periodically either every seven or every
17 years and I did a lot of research on
Skid I got a notebook remember those old
Novak's maybe you still have them
there's sort of black and white barley
on the front right with a label I got
one of those and I went to the library
and I wrote up all this stuff about
cicadas I have no idea why I did that
but I did it and of course I had three
older brothers who gave me no end of
grief for doing something like that but
in any case to me it was indicative of
my interest in science but of course I
was still just a person and so you know
then the late 60s came that was the
early sixties the late 60s came and I
began to spend much more of my time at
the fillmore east which no longer exists
anymore you know watching Jimi Hendrix
concerts than I did doing any research
on cicadas but eventually I emerged at
that and we despite the fact that i did
an undergraduate degree in anthropology
and in history two majors I still
maintain
an interest the whole time I was an
undergraduate and decided to go to
graduate school in science which is what
I did and that led to me sort of to the
next stage of my life of being a basic
scientist well one of the interests I
told you I had was in nature so when I
approached science I wanted to somehow
be outdoors and be in nature and so
there you see this is my first research
project i'm a little furrier in this
photo than i am now and this is taken
probably about thirty two years ago and
where i am there is actually in the
foothills to the Himalayas I'm up in at
about 10,000 feet and it's very faint
because of the lining but in the back
you'll see some white cat mounds those
are the really big ones that's the pier
punjab will ck to and non-gaap are be
the tallest mountains in the world and I
spent two years actually living up in
the foothills of the Himalayas and what
I was doing actually was studying these
again it's a little faint but these are
rhesus monkeys that live up in the
northern altitudes northern latitudes
and very high altitudes very unusual for
primates and so a close friend of mine
and the woman who has eventually become
my wife they were going to go out and do
this research and I decided since I was
a geneticist I'm going to figure out a
way to integrate my interest in genetics
into this project and and I went out as
well and we live there along with
several other people for a number of
years so what I would I went out to do
something and I'm going to tell you give
you the punchline first and this is
really important if you want to be a
scientist I went out and spent two years
doing research to prove something that I
ended up not proving I failed to prove
this in fact what everyone said was true
was true and I was wrong and that's
really important to confront because
that happens over and over again when
you do science so this is what we call
jelly bean genetics because the
prevailing theory at that time i work an
area called population genetics that is
how or how is genetic variation
distributed in populations and why
okay the prevailing theory was that
genes basically spread throughout a
population in a random fashion so it
would be like if you closed your eyes
and just stuck your hand in the
jellybean jar and pulled out a jellybean
well if you look at the one on the Left
you'll see nine of them are red and one
is yellow so your chance of getting a
red one is ninety percent right and
that's basically what the theory was it
is whatever the frequency of the genes
are in the population that's what will
be sampled from in creating the next
generation and that's it and that's how
it will proceed just now I couldn't
believe that that was true and the
reason I couldn't believe is true
because when you look at how monkeys are
organized they're socially organized
their social mammals they have these
polygamist social groups with multiple
males multiple females that mate with
one another the females actually never
leave the group they're born into they
stay in that group their whole life and
their daughters do and their
granddaughters do okay so that to me
said it can't be random because they're
not moving so every group can't be a
random selection of all the genes in the
whole population because they're not
moving the males on the other hand are
dispersing all over and there is a
skewed sex ratio so there are many many
more females at adulthood than there are
males even though at Birth that's not
true because what do males do they
engage in risky behavior and they die
right they get injured and they die
that's not that different from humans
right adolescent males engage in very
risky behavior and often get themselves
hurt also there's a very high variance a
lot of variability and reproductive
output in males not in females females
seem to have offspring out of regulates
every year every other year males
there's a dominance hierarchy if they
get beat up and run off they don't
actually mate with females and so
there's a lot of variability so I looked
at all this and I said it can't be jelly
bean genetics this can't be the way it
works there's some non-random way in
which genes are being dispersed
throughout the population so we went out
this is the range that's that that sort
of stippled area that's the range of the
rhesus monkey it has the biggest range
of any primate other than humans it's a
huge range and there is the part you can
see the red circle this Assefa know if
it has a light but if you see the red
circle you'll see that's the air we are
working in the north
see it says nwfp the north-west frontier
province of Pakistan to spectacularly
beautiful area it's gotten a lot of bad
press lately obviously because of recent
events over the last 10 years or so but
it's an absolutely spectacular area and
ecologically very interesting area okay
so we did genetics the hard way because
we couldn't do it the way you can do now
that is to get DNA using these
techniques that you've all seen on CSI
or whatever you just need a tiny little
bit of material and you can get all the
DNA you want we couldn't do that then we
had to actually get blood samples so we
had to trap these animals take blood
samples we had to do it in a in a very
responsible manner tranquilize the
animals keep them till they were fully
up only get whole groups at once take
the whole group back to their home range
and release them all at once everything
had to be done and I can actually say
that about 500 trappings we never lost
an animal's so I'm really pleased that
we that happened and all the groups were
fine after we released them but anyway
it was very very tough work so what did
I find okay this pie-chart won't mean
much until as I explained it if in fact
right that it is just random the way the
genes are moving around the population
right then that pie which represents the
total amount of genetic diversity in
this area that we worked in that pie
right most of it right should be of that
stippled type okay when you see a pie
where most of it is stupid like that
that means genes are basically Luke
being distributed around the population
at random it means that all the genetic
variation in the area can be found in
every single one of these social groups
because it's just moving over the
landscape and that's what you see and
only four percent of that variation
actually is made up of differences
between groups which is tiny this is
essentially random I was wrong it is
jellybean genetics okay but I still
couldn't believe that that was I mean I
didn't come all this way to find out
that I was wrong so we looked at samples
from other areas you see those different
letters of sampling other parts of the
range and we looked at it at different
levels the one I just showed you is in
the upper left then we looked at
differences between local populations
within the region
which is the one in the upper right
again most of the circle is stiffel
which means the genes are being randomly
stood over an even larger area than we
thought a whole region then we looked at
regions within this range of the species
most of the genetic variation in the
entire species can be found in little
social groups or in local populations
showing you it is just completely random
the way the genetic variation going I
still wasn't satisfied as I said I
didn't come all this way to be wrong so
I looked at other species again the same
thing I'm still wrong okay now the
reason for this probably is because of
these dispersing males because males
leave the group they're born into when
they become sexually mature and they may
go to multiple groups over the course of
their lifetime so imagine the landscape
where these males are moving around and
what are they doing they're leaving
their genes wherever they go okay so
that's why this thing is when you look
at a genetic variation that's
contributed by both parents meaning what
we have in our nuclear genome right all
those chromosomes there's so much coming
in from the male's that it's
overwhelming the fact that the females
are not moving around and is giving this
basically a random distribution of
genetic variation that's the explanation
but still females are not moving around
so I said I've got to find the signature
the genetic signature for females not
moving around it's got to be there
somewhere and where was it well this is
a again a little hard to see this is
another species of macaque monkey you
see the the mother and them in the
middle and then you'll see a bunch of
different offspring of different ages
that's what you see when you look at
social groups there'll be a series of
adult males and then you'll see their
offspring mostly their female offspring
because the male offspring move off once
they become mature right so what I
looked at was I tried to find something
that is inherited through the maternal
line now I don't know how many of you
know this you probably should know this
from your high school biology classes
that we have two different genomes in
our cells we have the genome we normally
talk about which are the chromosomes in
the nucleus of the cell but we have this
other genome in these little energy
producing factories called mitochondria
in ourselves and they have their own DNA
and that DNA is that circular loop of
DNA you see on the right side very small
but a good signature why is it a good
signature because everybody in here is a
clone of their mother went with respect
to mitochondrial DNA because you get the
mitochondrial DNA from the cytoplasm of
the egg there are some mitochondria in
the sperm but they never get
incorporated into the fertilized egg so
all you have are copies of the
mitochondria any of your mother okay so
I said now if I look at something that
is strictly maternally inherited I'm
going to have to pick up a signature of
the fact that females are not moving
around because males are not
contributing to that I'm going to get
this right and I did fantastic so
instead of the pie on the left which is
the nuclear variation where you find in
the chromosomes being mostly stippled
you can see there's only a small amount
of it is stippled on the right pi and
that is that's the amount of variation
that shared among groups and populations
and the black part is the mounted a
total variation that's unique and why is
it unique because the females are born
in a group they have a particular
mitochondrial genetic makeup and they
never leave that group they stay in that
group their whole life their daughters
stay in that group their granddaughters
stay in that group and so you can see
that it becomes highly specialized or
highly localized in each little area and
there are big differences between the
areas where as the nuclear variation is
pretty much homogenized across the
landscape so I did actually find this
and what it did was so I was completely
failed in my original experiment natural
experiment but it forced me to go and
take a look at this and i found this
signature of this the way in which
females are organized in populations it
led me to look more at mitochondrial DNA
i don't have time to go into it but
mitochondrial DNA has become a very very
important tool in evolutionary genetics
and it led me to do a lot of research on
that and how it works out not only in
populations at the present but how it
plays itself out over time and the fact
that when you reconstruct evolutionary
history using mitochondrial DNA you get
a very different picture than when you
use nuclear DNA and what you're getting
is two snapshots and you can also use
y-chromosome DNA that only comes through
the maternal line you get three snaps
you get these three snapshots of what
happened over evolutionary time in any
given point and you put those three
snapshots together and you get a real
story whereas if you just used one you'd
only get what I would say is a bias
story so this was a lot of fun and I
decided I would work on all these other
kinds of monkeys and I started working
on Apes and all kinds of other primates
and doing the same kind of work and then
while I was happily going about doing
this this was in nineteen this would be
1986 now if you see that circle that
just popped up on the slide did everyone
see that over in the lower left corner I
was doing work on the island of Sri
Lanka there's everyone knows Sri Lanka
it's off the South the southern coast of
the peninsula India and I was doing work
in Sri Lanka right as the Civil War was
going into full steam which was
interesting in and of itself I have many
stories about that that I could tell and
something happened and the thing that
happened actually changed the course of
my research life completely and probably
changed the course of my life completely
so I was driving down the road we had
all the provisions we needed we were
often a relatively remote area we were
working on a different species of
primate another monkey actually not
terribly distantly related from the
rhesus monkey and had the Jeep all
loaded up with provisions we were headed
up now for about two or three months and
on the way to the field site came upon
an elephant okay now this is an Asian
elephant asian elephants for the most
part don't have the large tusks like the
African elephants their ears are
different their ears are smaller they
tend to be a little bit smaller now
anyone who's ever spent any time with
elephants know that despite the fact
that elephants are large and most of the
films you see of elements are them
charging and making a lot of noise
elephants are incredibly quiet when they
want to be credibly quiet so I pulled
the Jeep off to the side of the roads
the first time I'd seen a wild elephant
stop turn the engine off and SAT there
watching the elephant for the longest
time and what elephants do you talk to
anyone who's done research on elephants
what the elephant did was eventually the
elephant just disappeared but it does is
it slowly
it's off to the forest but very very
slowly near perceptively and they're
almost sudden it's gone okay and then
you start asking did we just see an
elephant but we did see an omen this was
spectacular me I this was a really
really great I told you I really like
nature so you can imagine I thought this
was an incredible moment so we go up to
the research site we spend two months
there we're running out of things I
decided to drive back and I drive back
and that's the area that we I just
showed you that's what the area looks
like and if you can't see because it
sort of faded the entire forest was
burned to the ground completely burned
to the ground there were no animals
there were no birds and no elephants i
think was just had been completely
cleared for a big development project
that forest were they were were gone so
i suddenly struck me that i could
continue going on studying these various
species and having a lot of fun and
traveling to really cool places around
the world but at some point they would
all be gone or greatly diminished or i
could try to use my science perhaps to
do something about the fact that all of
these species and their habitats were
disappearing or really their habitats
and then the species we disappear so
this was a real game changer for me and
so then i became more of an applied
scientist although the problem i have is
i never drop anything so then I just
kept my basic science going and now i've
added applied science to it you'll see
and then i'll add more things on to and
what i did was i came down in altitude
instead of being in it at high altitude
or in very dry forest I went to low
altitudes and very wet forest which were
areas under really extreme pressure
where lots of habitat was disappearing
very very quickly this is a picture in
Sumatra this forest is actually gone
it's not there anymore so these forests
I'll talk about deforestation later and
I started studying all kinds i branched
out I didn't just work on primates but I
started working on all kinds of other
vertebrates in these forests so I'll
give you an example of how you take the
science of genetics and apply it to a
real problem so this is the manga topaz
the job in rhino that lives in Southeast
Asia it's probably it is the most
endangered large
amal in the world they are probably
somewhere in their region of 70 to 80 of
them left in the wild there are none in
captivity okay so it's a species really
on the brink and I'm going to talk about
molecular evolutionary tree building
that is building evolutionary trees
using molecular data okay so there's the
Javan rhinoceros you see it has a single
horn at the end just one horn some of
the Rhinos the ones in Africa for
instance have two horns and this is a
very rare photo in that the photo is of
the animal out during the day it's rare
that job and rhinos will come out during
the day and I'll explain why in a little
bit okay so many people believe that the
javan rhino that was just a subspecies
of the other one horn Rhino which you
can see over on the left sometimes
called the greater one-horned rhino or
the Indian Rhino okay and we wanted to
find out whether that was true because
if it's just a subspecies and they're
very few individuals left you might not
put so much time and effort into it and
you might put more time and effort into
those other populations that you see in
Nepal and India because they're larger
and they're more viable okay so we used
molecules to reconstruct an evolutionary
tree and that's basically a tree of
relationships and as you can see where
the red circle is the one on top which
says rhinoceros unicornis that's the
bigger one and the one on the bottom
that's the job in run sunday ACCA's okay
now if you look along the branch as
you'll see numbers if you add those two
numbers up 52 and 53 it tells you how
much evolutionary divergence there has
been how many nucleotides in the DNA
have changed since they shared a common
ancestor in the particular genes that we
were looking at and you'll see it's a
hundred and five now people said that
they were subspecies of one species well
this is interesting was interesting to
us because if you look down here and you
add 42 and 69 right you get a hundred
and eleven so there are only 111
differences between the white rhino and
the black rhino of Africa and those are
not considered two separate species
they're considered in two separate
general two different general which is a
very very significant evolutionary
difference in order to say they're in
each and a different genus okay where's
the ones on top which are just as
different we're thought to be subspecies
of the same
species so we reported this back the
saying this is clearly not true these
are at least separate species if not
each and a separate genus and have had
their own evolutionary history separated
from the other for a very long period of
time okay so in the language that we use
we said these two groups of organisms
are evolutionarily significant units you
might call them species or gender or
whatever okay we're just calling them
evolutionary significant units then we
thought well we're going to look at the
Javan run because there are two
populations one in Vietnam and one in
the island of Java you can see them
there now you see the one on the left
that picture is a picture that was taken
with a photo camera trap and the recent
second with a camera trap which is a
beam of light and when the animal
crosses the beam of light the camera
flashes a picture the reason is that
almost all of these animals not by
nature not by their evolutionary history
but because of strong selection by the
human population are nocturnal they only
come out at night because the ones that
came out there in a day got shot ok so
you strongly select for individuals that
will only come out at night and so the
only way to find out whether there is
the set up a camera trap have them cross
this beam and take a picture of it
otherwise you'd never know they're there
I mean I've worked in the National Park
in Indonesia where they they are you
John cool on national park and there are
Park guards who have been there for
years and have never seen a job in rhino
soon as you put our camera traps bingo
the next night you find job and rhinos
okay in any case these are the two
populations in cat lock in Vietnam and
anuj on coolin in the island of Java and
we wanted to look at the differences and
indeed if you look at again add up the
numbers on the branches you'll see that
these are just as different as these two
subspecies are a black rhino and those
two subspecies of black rhino have had
so many millions of dollars poured into
their conservation because they're
separate subspecies and yet no one ever
thought to look at these and when we
looked at them we found out that they
were just as different and really
required each of them requiring their
own separate management and their own
separate investment and so you'll see we
use this other term mu which is a
management unit and we define these two
units in Vietnam and John kula in Java
now there's our job in rhino again and
there is who John cool on national park
that's the where they are now there's an
interesting thing how many of you know
about Krakatoa or crack at all right so
you know that Krakatoa is or crack at AO
the real name is misspelled here
actually in a map created by the new
york times they do get things wrong
there was a movie that came out back
when I was a kid called Krakatoa east of
Java the age I think it had like
Charlton Heston or who I don't know who
was in two interesting things first of
all its crack at Owl not Krakatoa and
secondly it's west of job and not east
of Java but other than that the title
was totally accurate if you look there
you'll see its way out on the tip of the
island of Java right now if you know
about Krakatoa you know in 1883 Krakatoa
blew it was such an enormous explosion
that actually it covered the atmosphere
with a layer of dust that blocked out
that block out the Sun but diminished
the rays of the Sun so much so that it
actually snowed in Boston and July
that's how cool it was ok the sound of
this was heard and the effects of this
were heard in Europe and this is
happening on the island of Java so you
can get a sense it caused the tsunami
just like the tsunami that that we had
recently in the Indian Ocean hitting
exactly the same places because the
entire volcano collapsed into the ocean
causing this huge reverberating waves
going out hit exactly the same places in
Indonesia in India in Sri Lanka the only
difference was the population was very
small at that time and people were not
living along the coast because that was
not a good place to live everyone knew
that and so the number of deaths were
actually fairly minimal but essentially
happened now what concerns me about
having most of the job and runs is
ninety percent of job and rhinos there
is this picture right here if you look
at that picture closely you'll see it
looks like a volcano and that's what it
is this is called anak Krakatau
on that crocodile means son of Krakatau
and what's happening is that fault line
is still there and so it's just growing
back up and it's growing back up quickly
at about one foot a month that grows
that peak you see is growing about one
foot a month okay now eventually that's
going to blow and if all of your job and
rhinos are in that basket right there
that's it for the job in right now so we
have made we've said this is a very
important management unit of the job and
rhinos the most important one and that
you have to disperse these animals into
other areas find other suitable habitat
disperse them into other areas there are
other genetic reasons for doing that so
that's that's basically how we're using
genetics to try to develop management
plans for species okay okay but then I
realized that you how many species there
are there are millions of species there
any people like me you would need you
don't really don't want more than one of
me but we sort of do the things I do you
would need you know you would need
millions to come up with management
plans for all these different species
that's not going to happen there aren't
the people there isn't the money it's
not going to happen so we have to begin
to think about how we're going to attack
some of these issues on a much much
larger scale so then I added another
layer which I call citizen scientist
which is the scientist trying to take
his science or her science and use it to
help policymakers develop the very best
policy based on science you probably
don't remember the UN millennium summit
in two thousand but you do know a few
weeks ago they was celebrating the 10th
anniversary here in New York of this and
the same thing was true in two thousand
and two thousand ten the most impressive
part to New Yorkers about this was the
how bad the traffic was in the city and
how impossible it was to get to midtown
and how annoyed they were that they were
doing this but it actually did something
in addition to that and it created
something called the Millennium
Development Goals which some of you may
have heard of them maybe not a large
number of you that's part of the problem
but some of you may have heard about
them one of the Millennium Development
Goals I mean they're really good goals
eradicate poverty achieve primary
education promote gender equality reduce
child mortality I mean this is all mom
and
papai stuff everybody wants to do this
one of them was ensure environmentally
sustainable ax t and I was asked to
co-chair a task force on this and we
created this report out of that task
force environment in human wellbeing a
practical strategy okay and unlike many
other UN reports which usually are
released everyone at some big event and
their copies piled up there and at the
end of it there's champagne for everyone
for the release of the report and
everyone takes one of these back to
their office and puts it on their shelf
it collects dust in about two every two
years they clean out their office it
goes into the round file and that's the
end of the year that's the general life
history of a UN report we decided we
would actually try to make this stick a
little bit so in that picture on the
bottom we have actually officials from a
variety of countries that we were hoping
that had come forward and asked us if we
would try to apply some of our
recommendations in their country what
does the report say the most important
sentence in the report is the following
environmental sustainability is
essential to achieving all other
Millennium Development Goals you're not
going to get gender equality you're not
going to reduce infant mortality and I
could get any of those things done
poverty reduced slum dwelling and all
that if in fact the very infrastructure
upon which all of those problems are
hinged is eroding out from under you so
what we argued was that nature was the
infrastructure and that all of those
things that we think we need every day
which we do right they all actually are
related to the nature and the condition
that nature is in and if you translate
this into the Millennium Development
Goals speak environmental sustainability
is at the center of everything and all
the other problems you see are symptoms
of a core disease and the core disease
is the decline of nature that's the core
disease and everything else is a symptom
well you can attack the symptoms that's
what medicine does all the time is
attack symptoms but if you asked any
public health specialist they will tell
you that is a very expensive way of
going about dealing with a problem
prevention is much cheaper
dealing with symptoms so how do we
achieve environment sustainability i'll
give you one way in which you're doing
it ok so we've heard about this problem
with increasing atmospheric carbon
dioxide and increasing land land and
ocean temperatures right now people may
argue about what the cause of this is
but no one can argue that this is
happening because you can measure it
fairly readily ok so you've seen both of
those are going up over time this is a
period I'm really looking at the period
from like 1960 on but obviously it's
been going up for a much longer period
of time than that we've also seen
another thing and that is increases in
deforestation around the world very high
levels of deforestation around the world
why should why does that matter really
well with rising temperatures we have
rising sea levels at doesn't matter from
Morningside Heights we're pretty far
above the sea level but if you live in
one of the small island developing
states in the Pacific and you're maybe
one meter above sea level it matters a
lot one sea level goes up many of those
countries have already created
evacuation plans for their entire
country they're expecting their entire
country to go underwater that's pretty
amazing if you think about it we've seen
tropical storm severity there's still a
lot of argument about whether increased
surface temperatures the ocean is what's
causing increases in tropical storm
severity it's a great area for
scientific research it's not at all
resolved and biodiversity loss and along
with the loss of biodiversity is the
loss of the services that those
biodiverse that biodiversity supplies
risk for instance water quality and pest
control pollination and disease
buffering so there are all those
consequences okay so how do we fix this
problem well scientists say we have to
keep the temperature at about two
degrees centigrade above what it was in
pre-industrial time to do that we have
to stabilize co2 at about 450 parts per
million in the atmosphere which means
reducing industrialized country co2
emissions by eighty percent of 2000
levels by 2050 that means going eighty
percent below where we were two thousand
by 2050 is a huge task to attempt to
make this happen one of the ways we can
actually deal with this is controlling
tropical deforestation and I would
imagine that very few of you know that's
a good way to control
co2 emissions right because you think
mostly a factories we think of the left
you don't think of the right okay so
they're the three big forests the Amazon
the congo basin and the island of New
Guinea okay and these are all the
reasons that forests are taken down
cattle ranching agriculture mining
timber emissions from deforestation if I
told you I'm wondering if you would
believe me but one acre of forest of
tropical forest disappears every second
okay think of what an acre is okay some
of you live in houses maybe you live on
a quarter of an acre plot think of an
acre forest disappears every second okay
so many acres of tropical forests have
disappeared since I started talking once
city block is about five and a half
acres so that means in five and a half
seconds a far as the size of an entire
city block right will disappear about
fifteen percent of the emission co2
emissions annually into the atmosphere
come from deforestation that's one out
of every seven tons that goes into the
atmosphere comes from deforestation
right and so if this continues the way
it is going all of those emission
reductions that have been achieved
through the Kyoto Protocol will be
completely eradicated over the same
period of time by all the deforestation
that's going on to give you another view
of this this first and second biggest
emitters this is a two thousand graph
those have actually flipped China is now
the biggest emitter but China United
States are the biggest emitters of co2
right the third and fourth largest
emitters of co2 or Indonesia and Brazil
and they do not have large industrial
complexes that's coming from
deforestation 75% of that come from
deforestation okay and they are the
third and fourth largest emitters of co2
they emit more co2 than Japan they emit
more co2 than any European country they
emit more co2 than any other country
except the United States and and China
because of this deforestation so let me
show you what far is covered
trends look like in a country over time
you start out with a lot of forest and
then a lot of it gets cut in the
tropical country then it sort of
stabilizes out and if the country has
achieved some level of economic
development it begins to replant
plantation forests to cover lands that
were formerly forested okay you can find
countries at different stages here we're
working with many many other people
around the world way just one group to
do something okay there is already
something called the Clean Development
Mechanism to try to promote the planting
of forest we're trying to work on a
mechanism called reduced emissions from
deforestation and degradation red which
is trying to change that curve flatten
that curve out so you don't get all that
deforestation to start with now you
might ask well that's nice how you going
to do that right after all it's been
going on what makes you so smart well
here's the logic okay if a hectare of
forest does everyone know what a hectare
measure is it's about two and a half
acres it's how most of the world
measures land we use acres but most of
the world uses hectares so it's two and
a half acres so if a hectare forest is
cleared the carbon stored that's going
to go up into the atmosphere all of its
going to go eventually a hectare of
intact more it's close of tropical
forest say in the amazon has about a
hundred and fifty to two hundred and
forty tons of carbon but we measure
what's going to happen as co2 so we have
to add two molecules of oxygen to that
and we have to create co2 and that means
if you remember your chemistry that
means oxygen is a little heavier than
carbon so in fact it's not three times
the amount it's three point six seven
times the amount so it means there's
about 500 27 or 50 tons of co2
equivalents in one hectare 12 an F acre
plot you cut it down and burn it goes up
to the atmosphere okay 750 tons of co2
so not cutting it means you're not
emitting 750 tons of co2 okay now a
forest own in Brazil who decides not to
cut that so he's not emitting co2 750
tons of co2 should receive the same
carbon credits than a factory owner in
Belgium who reduces his emissions by
seven or 50 tons but you want to know
what that far
it gets that far so he gets nothing
factory owner gets probably something on
the order of ten to twenty dollars per
ton factory owner gets I mean the forest
owner gets nothing this doesn't make any
sense in terms of equity it doesn't make
any sense in terms of trying to prevent
the far from being cut down makes even
less sense so what red is trying to do
is say if you don't cut down your forest
okay we can show we can measure to
within ninety eight percent accuracy how
much co2 you're not putting up into the
atmosphere and those can be turned into
what are called emissions reduction
units which is what they're doing in
Europe now right for factory owners and
you get emissions reduction units that
you can sell on the market why are you
selling on the market because there's a
factory somewhere in Indiana or in
Helsinki or whatever that wants to admit
the co2 and in order for them to reduce
their co2 it's very expensive to refit
their Factory so what they can do is
they can buy your reductions instead of
emitting themselves now some of you
might get oh this is crazy and I don't
have the time to explain but after if
people want to stay I'll explain this in
more detail but what we did was we
brought the science into this and said
look let's look at what we're trying to
do scientifically okay let's integrate
this into economics and policy and let's
create a policy that's going to provide
an economic incentive for forest owners
not to cut their forests to ask far zone
is not to cut their forests for the good
of humankind is going to work as well as
everything else you ask people to do for
the good of humankind mean not at all
okay but if you can provide an economic
incentive then in fact you can get
something done and that's what we're
trying to do here and this is just
showing the kinds of costs you have to
these are the opportunity costs that
you're forgoing if you do soybeans or
ranching or all that and that's what
we're trying to match so I looked up
today on price carbon which is a website
that has the price of these emission
reduction units and today emission
reduction unit will actually it was
friday was worth twenty one dollars and
seventy cents so now think about a
hectare of forest that's 750 tons at $21
get out you're whatever electronic
device of one sort or another your
smartphone or whatever
don't use it as a phone but you can do
your calculation and you'll see that
it's actually quite a bit of money per
hectare now imagine if you own 10,000
hectares right this is your community on
10,000 hectares you're a community I
work with communities now in Colombia
who threw my counterparts in Colombia
who have a hundred thousand hectares
okay now you're talking about a real
economic incentive not to cut the forest
n and when you don't cut the forest down
you're not emitting co2 into the
atmosphere and you're not losing the
forest and all the services that it
supplies soil stabilization and
everything else that it supplies all
those things I took the biodiversity
within it ok so the idea is multilateral
agreements to limit carbon emissions
we're hoping they're in the works if
they're extended to avoided
deforestation so you can monetize not
cutting down the forest you now have a
competing value for the forests versus
logging or agriculture anything else and
it's been at least modeled that about 20
billion dollars into the market for a
voided deforestation will cut tropical
deforestation in half worldwide that 20
billion dollars is nothing I mean it may
seem like a lot to you and it is a lot
but I mean in a capital market it's
nothing it's a roundoff error 20 billion
dollars and that would cut tropical
deforestation worldwide in half ok so
this is the way in which you can bring
science economics and policy together in
the hopes of trying to make major
transformations they're going to have
huge implications for biodiversity and
huge implications for ecosystems in
which that biodiversity lives ok so let
me just sum up because I've been out
here long so if you become a scientist
you can have fun in the field ok going
really cool places you can have fun in
the lab if labs or places you like to
have fun in in addition you get to do
things like this like here I'm signing
an agreement with the Prime Minister
Papua New Guinea to help launch a
national program Papua New Guinea
there's Papua New Guinea perhaps the
most interesting place I've ever been to
in my life but I don't have time to tell
you why it's the eastern
a half of the island of New Guinea you
can even do this which happened about 10
days ago I had a meeting with the
president of the Dominican Republic an
impromptu meeting and you know where I
am who knows where I am I'm in the
Columbia bookstore I'm standing in the
Columbia bookstore there's the president
in the middle and the first lady to to
my right his left and we were discussing
a project that he invited me to do in
the Dominican Republic which we're
currently doing and he was here for the
UN General Assembly and he absolutely
loves books by the way I need to back up
and say one other thing I know I'm
talking a lot but this Prime Minister
this is Sir Michael samari prime
minister he is actually the George
Washington of Papua New Guinea he is the
father of Papua New Guinea he took Papua
New Guinea independent 35 years ago he
was Prime Minister than he wasn't Prime
Minister now he's Prime Minister again
it's an extraordinary individual
actually the leonel fernandez the
president of the mics books so he
happened to be in the columbia bookstore
and he had his one of his colleagues the
man on the left give me a call I only
lived two blocks in the Colonia
bookstore so I ran down really quickly I
was watching the Giants game and said I
figure I wasn't watching the Giants game
in in a in a suit i quickly changed
anyway we're working in this area you
see in the lower right so you get to do
stuff like that dominican republic and
so how how can you live the life of an
active scientists come to colombian get
your feet wet okay thanks a lot
you